this is so exciting I mean one word
gutsy it says it all congratulations on
the success of this show you know when
you think about the trailblazing women
that the both of you reached out to to
be a part of this this series is that
the two of you making personal phone
calls are you like dream casting who's
gonna be in our show how did that all
work sometimes yeah it was sometimes and
we though we're so lucky to work with an
amazing team you know from hidden light
from Apple TV plus and so and it very
much was a team effort so sometimes it
was us calling sometimes it was other
people calling and we're just so proud
of everyone who's in the show which
guest that you had on the show from the
world of Hollywood left you the most
stunned or surprised oh that's tough
question yeah
um you know they were they were
different they were different you know
for example I will never forget Wanda
Sykes who was so smart in talking about
how comedy should always be aimed up
throw the Rocks up not the Rocks down
Kim Kardashian was unlike anything thing
you've ever seen and because you know
she is serious about trying to help
people who are incarcerated unfairly for
too long making the stallion was
so calm and impressive as we were
painting with her she also had a lot
more Talent than we did which which
surprised no one and I would just say
ing Horace was extraordinary and just so
wise and full of such purpose and such
Pride for her Heritage and such like
ferocity in her determination to save
our planet for all of us so I just want
to include her too it's important work
and obviously you know you've made such
a mark with with all of the amazing work
that you've done throughout your career
I'm curious have you ever considered
joining the world of politics well I
think all of us right now are political
I mean particularly if you're a woman in
America when we have politicians
deciding they know what's best for our
bodies rather than we knowing what's
right for ourselves so I think we all
are political I have no plans to run for
public office but I care but I care
deeply about being an Engaged Citizen
and deeply about ensuring that my
children have even more rights than I've
had and unfortunately that's not the
direction we're going in right now but
I'm optimistic we'll be able to change
it bring up your children what's it like
watching your baby be such a stellar
mother it is one of the greatest moments
of Pride and gratitude that you could
describe I mean she's a fabulous mom
and you know I used to hear that from my
friends who got to be grandparents
before I did she was very eager to
become a grandmother she'd be like you
know you heard that yeah
so my mother-in-law already had 20
grandchildren so there was like no
pressure from that side and my mom was
like any day now would be a great day
you laid it on thick it sounds like she
did I wasn't subtle at all are you
Grandma to the kids yeah grandma that's
right what is this beautiful woman like
as a grandmother oh she's such a good
grandmother like she loves playing with
my kids and reading with my kids and
doing arts and crafts with my kids and
probably nothing more though than
gardening with my kids which is like so
fun so it's great I love seeing my mom
as a grandma my final question Dorinda
medley has said you are a fan of Real
Housewives of New York is that true are
you a fan well I'm a fan of hers yeah I
knew her before she was a real housewife
and I did see one episode of her okay
what do you think I I think she was
terrific but I don't know if that rises
level of fan of the show but of her
absolutely I love that the clintons are
so normal you guys watch House lives
like the rest of us do oh you got it I
mean don't get my mother started talking
about interior decorating I love those
shows I mean man in 30 minutes you go
from this to that I mean it's amazing
magic the Transformation Magic yes
congratulations on your honor wonderful
speaking with both of you thank you so
much take care bye
foreign